OH MY GOD, IT'S JACKSEPTICYEYE!!
AHHHHHH
Oh, hey how's it going bros?
Welcome back to another episode of "Resident Evil 7"
Alright, so,  right off the bat, I read you bro's comments and,
apparently a little hidden secret down here
that I missed completely
So I appreciate the little tips and tricks that you bros give me.
What do we have?
A box!
Hehehehehe.... Box!!
Hell Yea motha' fucka'
Alright,
Nice little creepy shed there, appreciate it.
Uhh, now we have,
I guess we have a broken hand gun and
a broken shotgun
I'm just gonna repair the broken hand gun cause
I can't be bothered to go and get the broken shotgun
Is that okay with you?
Great,
Great I'm glad we agree on things
Broken handgun
Alright great
Uhh, use it on the repair kit
Excellent
Oh they have different max? Okay, okay
okay
more ammo for me. Is there anything else we need?
I think we're good to rock and roll
MothaFucka
let's do this we're going to the party
Hell Yeah! I used to work at a night club
So uh, I know how to handle the fucked
up drunk people
oh my god it's bleach I mean hey bro
doesn't even load
HEY POODS
Hey bro its a fucking nice atmosphere in there.
lot of hoes, lot of bitches
G-go on in
alright alright bro man bleach such a
bro who would have thought
lets
play
yay
oh how nice
alright i can't play for too long today
because it saturday and i usually take
Saturdays off i will spend it with Marzia so..
I know this was probably a bit
shorter. Dude not so close
Jesus Christ
ETHAN BRADBERRY
He's so fuckin creepy
Oh great an alien fetus
I don't know... a dildo?
Oh, god.... no
AGH!
Who's Eveline?
Found ya'll?
Yes, that's me
Bradberry
Ohh baby~
Oh I'll come through you
I'll come through you with my.... dick!
AH, shit.. haha nice, nice- fuck indeed
alright so we have a new gun i suppose
no we don't have a new gun
Uhh...
Uh fuck..uhh
Relatively powerful. Great, great just fucking great
How's it look? Looks pretty cool..
PEWDS you should have a shotgun! God dammit!
Why didn't you tell me then?!
Heh!
Oh geez, is that a trap?
Oh my god.. it's a BOX!!!
Handgun ammo!
what if you just go underneath- Hey!
high five! fuck yeah!
He-hey! High five!
i have no friends.
Right on her ass. Nicely placed
mate. Nicely placed not very discreet
though! But nicely placed. OH god another one
Fuck, they're everywhere. Hey barrel how you
doing y-you look pretty good man
Can I crawl underneath? Fuck, I got a cold, man.
WAIT, there's a treasure hidden here!
I recognize this place
WHAT! HELL YEAH! WHAAAT! WHAAT
WHA- Oh shit oh shit there's a trap in the
fucking ceiling
Okay so now we can repair the shotgun too,
that's pretty good
I don't know why we need to do that
Can I shoot it from here I don't fucking trust this.
No it was pretty fucking obvious
Hey bro how you doin, you look pretty good
Alright, so what else we got? Huh?
Nothin? ETHAN BRADBERRY!
BOX!!
My new favourite catchphrase, everyone.
BOX!
Ugh, god damnit
Oh, for fuck's sake!
What, s-so the boxes have explos- Awh for f-
What's over here?
Nothin. Great.
Ooh! GOTEM!
Shut the fuck up.
Why is this here?
What the fuck? It doesn't make a-
I don't need this many guns
Right?
I don- I don't know man.
There we go.
Actually I don't need to hold the repair kit either
Fuck saake
We'll go get the broken shotgun later
This is a perfect timing.
What.
How am I supposed to know
T-Hahahahaha!
Okay, sure.
Aghh!
What did he say? 0, 1, 5
I have a bad feeling about this.
What the fuck did you do?
WOAH!
Jesus!
For fuck's sake!
???
Ughh!
Wait
Haha!
Great, just great.
Just fucking fantastic.
I don't fucking trust boxes anymore
You were my only friend
You were supposed to be THE CHOSEN ONE!
There you go.
Fucking great.
Should I just shoot them from now on?
I don't
I don't know man.
Heey, look at that, shotgun.
Heh!
Burner fuel? I don't need it, great.
This corridor,
It's way too fucking set up.
Anytime you got a long ass fucking corridor
There's a trap there isn't it, yeah I see it.
It's right fucking here.
Gotem!
JESUS CHRIST!
Oh god
WATCH OUT FOR THE TRAP YOU MOTHERFUCKER!
Jeesus!
You almost got hurt!
Fuckin asshole!
Helloo?
Life's handing you lemons, so make lemonade then.
Oh god, oh god, moist monsters.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, baby
I missed
Oh god, reload reload RELOAD
Gotem!
GAADEM
I can't fuckin see!
Jesus Chriist!
Are they still aft- Ughh come on dude
Just fuckin die!
You fucking pancake looking motherfucker, I'm just gonna go.
Not gonna waste my fuckin ammo
Alright, this place looks wonderful doesn't it
Jesus Christ.
I'm so sick of the fucking trap
I swear to god if you're a trap box
Can't even trust a good ol' box these days
Is this- Is this guy for real
Can you just fuck off?
HOW?
Fucking die mother, fucker!
Jesus Christ!
No more traps, I'm fucking done with traps!
Hey piggy how ya doin'
Heey, how's it going it's Poodip- Haa!
BOX!
Ughh.
This looks like a- aw why do I ne- Okay nice.
This looks like a boss area doesn't it?
It's too wide and open.
Great
Ano- OH it's a hub here!
SAVE STATION, Gotta love ma save station!
Alright, now we can head off in the world.
Have a good time, ya know.
See what happens.
See what floats
Is that a trap?
I swear to god no more fucking traps.
Did I just take damage from jumpin down there?
God damnit.
Alright, what do we got?
You know what
Pop some pills.
Poppin dem pills
I don't trus-
Shotgun shells.
You trade one handgun ammo for one shot- oh yeah it's worth it.
Alright, so we're missing a battery
Cool.
Thanks game for telling me, appreciate it
There's really nothing else here it seems like.
Except broken dreams.
Oh there it is okay.
I swear to god if you're a broken- yeah fuck you.
And fuck you pig honestly, like
I swear to god, I swear to god, box.
AHH!!
Some people pointed out that during your playthrough
while you're playing the game
uhh
You didn't get a scar on your arm
or some shit like that
You see, I have a scar on my arm
I don't know it's pretty interesting I guess.
Well, we got the battery now.
I don't..
That's the gun
I'm getting really fucking tired of these fucking traps, man.
Noo!
NOOOOOO!
NOO!
Fuck this!
WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT?!
Oh my god, it's Jacksepticeye!
AHH!
NOO!
NOOOO!
Fucking bullshit.
Aw yeah, aw yeah, bring it on motherfucker!
Bring it on now fuc-
Jesus Cried (Christ)
Another one!
How are you still alive??
Are you fucking kidding me!
Are you fucking kidding me?!
JUST FUCKING DIE!
Disgusting! You're disgusting!
Oh my god, just sta-
YES!
Ugh!
Fat man down, everybady
Ahh fuck.
That means there's more?
Oh, ah thank you
Just took all my grenade launcher rounds.
All of em.
And up we go!
No? Okay. Heheh
It's the kind of thing where like you know, eeeeh
It doesn't matter what we do, we're always gonna lose cause we were set up...
...by this motherfucker
But I dunno man
C'mon, what is happening?
Oh!
Well that's embarrassing.
Not doing too shabby, I would say.
So, how-how are you doing today then?
Yeah?
Doin alright?
Havin a good day?
Havin a good time?
Oh look, it's you!
That would be weird if I walked in on you pla-
that would be some meta shit
N-no offense
I don't think you look like a zombie.
Don't get me wrong.
Al-although I don't know? Haha.
Hey how ya doin bud- you're next.
Well
Well, thank you kindly!
I suppose we hit the stairs.
Almost missed a coin!
Woo!
Weha!
After you!
God damnit
This part isn't scary, it's just fucking annoying.
Oh, do we have the code? I didn't, I didn't
catch a code. Is there a code back there?
Surely there must have been..
Four ae- There we go.
1408.
Alright
THAT'S why there was a box here
because we come back to this area.
Alright, now that I used all my fucking grenade sh-rounds
Can't use that anymore, switch back to the flame thrower.
Wherever it is- there we go.
1, 4
0 8.
YEYAH!
We did it!
Uhh-
God damnit.
Fuck you!
That's the real reason why the box is there!
Do I really got to get rid of-
Naw.
Ahhh, come on man.
Alright.
Maybe, all the weapons.
How does he know?
Really, you had to get rid of everything huh.
Aww, wait a minute!
Aww c-
Thank you, did you know it's my birthday?
Thank you.
Okay, so this is the puzzle that we played in the VHS tape.
Which I mean, should be pretty fuckin obvious then.
Cause all we gotta do is..
Uhh..
Whr- I was suppos- we gotta walk in here just st- start
the fucking puzzle.
Hey! It's ma birthday everybady! (hey howboudat)
It's, ma birthday
Shut the fuck up.
Hehahaha!
That's kinda creepy.
Hey that kind uhhh- NO!
No!
Oh shit, Jesus!
Uhh that kind of proves my point
So, he set us up to lose now
BUT
since we saw the VHS tape..
we could win with cheating!
That's kinda cool, I like that.
Hey balloons, how you doin everybady?
I can just see him blowing up all these balloons.
Loser..
Looo
seher.
Ah fuck sake.
Urmm
Loos-
ser.
Hey!
It's almost like we've done this before!
How about that
Good Game, GG man.
Now we have the valve..
This way, uhh
the oil won't run out and fucken burn us to death (in a horrible way)
Although, I'm not sure how he set up the fuckin valve to break, when you use it once.
Creepy.
Happy Birthday!
Yeah!
It's gonna blow up.
We knew that, why don't we take cover?
What the fuck?!
Oh god, uhh
URHHHH..
URRRHH SHIT PUT IT IN DUDE
Baaa!
I would get away from the oil if I were you.
Oh well.
Motherfucka!
Okay, I can only play a little bit more, I'm runnin out of time unfortunately.
This is really cool.
Oh we got it!
Fuck yeah!
EXcellent! Dude you look good.
Excellent.
Oh no, it's Mia.
Oh no.
Hurray!
God damn, I hate him.
Erherr, dick. Hahahaha!
And I don- SAVE TEETEETETETEEPEDEE
I guess it would be a good place to end it here.
Just really kinda wanna play a little bit more. Hehe.
I know I'm not supposed to- hey we have a map!
I'm REALLY sorry for cutting this one a little bit short but, uh it's all I can do for you today
I hope you enjoyed it regardless, and I'll see you tomorrow
with anothe- a-a longer episode
I PROMISE.
Thank you for watching, it means a lot. Stay awesome bros!